Our answer, interestingly enough is, a plus c over 2, b plus d over 2. To figure
out how we got to this final answer, let's start again with the x coordinate of
our midpoint. Our x coordinates of the two original points are a and c. And let's
say they want to start at a and move halfway towards c. First we find half the
distance between these two coordinates. Which is the distance, c minus a, just
divided by 2. Then you need to shift that over graphically so that we're
starting at point a, instead of starting at the origin. So we need to tack on a
distance in x of a. I said that I wanted your answer as a single fraction, so we
need to simplify this a little bit. Putting this all over one common denominator
gives us c minus a plus 2a, all over 2. And in the end we get c plus a over 2,
Or of course because of commutivity, a plus c over two. We do the same exact
thing for our y co-ordinate except of course we use the y values of these two
points. And we end up with d plus b over 2. Together, these two coordinates give
us our final midpoint.